foreign
what are they building are you doing
this actually no they built their own
Tech
pretty smart ants okay so when you were
all like like gone those five years I
am really into the quantum realm and oh
the quantum Realm
I know we all have a history there and I
didn't want to freak anyone out but
we've been talking about it she has some
questions okay I can't help if people
are inspired by me
so you've been studying the quantum
Realm
why didn't you ask me about it I tried
Mom
a lot you never wanted to talk about it
Cassie's just been curious and we gave
her some pointers this isn't exactly ant
science is it Henry
you know how dangerous the quantum realm
is we all do Mom nobody's going to the
quantum realm that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space or the
ocean
but
iguana
we just need a map
and then we can study and explore the
entire Quantum Realm
never even have to go
your daughter built a subatomic Hubble
telescope in a basement
I could have found him
it's amazing
I'm Blown Away
how does it work
it's kind of like that two-way radio we
used to have you send a signal down from
here and then it collects the data and
it sends it back wait wait a minute
you're sending a signal
down to the quantum Realm
yeah
shut it down now why would we shut it
you have to turn it off stop and tell us
what's wrong
there's something I should have told you
[Music]
[Applause]
let's do the Hat
foreign
okay are you okay yeah okay
where
are we
yes Mom
dad
are you okay
we should be dead
why aren't we I don't know
are we where I think we are
I would say yes but
it wasn't like this Janet
[Music]
get it
do not move
we need to find Scott and Kathy
right now
can you hear me
can anyone hear me oh my God
it's okay what are you gonna do it's
okay it's okay we're okay we're okay
it's gonna be okay you're saying okay
too much okay all right okay well it's
because we are we're okay
we are fine okay we're gonna find them
and we're gonna go home
in the meantime look around it's
beautiful
all right we're outside
it's like we're camping we love camping
we've never been camping
but we've always talked about it
is that Sun moving
I don't think this is his son
it's fine okay
that was weird
run
[Music]